gamora's survival from the invents of
the infinity war represents a cosmic
imbalance and the only way that she can
write that balance is by proving the
Living Tribunal that she can murder all
twenty Celestials it's gonna be Gamora
hunting the guardians I feel like she's
just gonna become kind of baby Thanos to
a degree she's got the sanctuary to
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars this is
rogue theory and today we're gonna guess
about Google Maura in Guardians three
I'm Philip Molina and going rogue
remotely of course today our Eric boss
hello happy to be back
my and then uh fresh from is a dip in a
vat of acid it's the Joker's new side
piece yeah hey guys I got bored and
destroyed my hair and that was Matt's
freaking fire alarm but we had to wait
till he put out the fire he started this
stupid hair this is how important rogue
theory is to me I went and put out a
fire to come back so I can talk to you
guys about stuff
you're the real hero I try man I try
it's not every day that we have Angelica
Trey yeah and your place looks like it's
on fire too but in the emoji way all
right guys let's get into it so we know
that Gomorrah was sacrificed by Thanos
an infinity war in 2018 that version of
Gomorrah right but then we got our 2014
Gomorrah who gets brought in in fights I
Thanos in an in-game that's a version of
Gomorrah that has never met the
guardians of the galaxy she survives the
events of endgame she didn't so that
would mean that she's not necessarily
part of Thanos his group if Tony snap
affected all Thanos's group so we know
that there's gonna be another Guardians
movie I'm thinking it's gotta be the
search for Gamora the search for Spock
equivalent of the Guardians trilogy so
pitch me how is gomorrah coming back in
guardians a galaxy vol 3 let's go rogue
i would normally start but i have minds
of a bit
brogre so i want to hear you guys so i
can steal from yours okay don't go let's
hear it
i'm thinking what if she comes back as a
bounty hunter
i don't know i feel we love bounty
hunters in space so why not have Gamora
be a bounty hunter
I'm thinking maybe we'll tie this in
with like rocket Rick Kuhns backstory
and somehow someway you know she'll find
her way on half world okay that's
interesting so she is she is one of the
the Guardians her bounty yeah yeah maybe
one or like all of them
Oh interesting so while they're trying
to find her cuz he know star was gonna
be trying to find her she's hunting them
yes
that's gonna be the movie I mean
obviously I think it would be really fun
to explore some of like Rockets
backstory but it's gonna be Gamora
hunting the Guardians I like that
because you know both rocket and Gamora
I think on that Xand are processing
screen they both have these like weird
mysterious cybernetic implants mm-hmm
that like they clearly weren't born with
some something put that in them and like
there's a story there right essentially
with rocket at least in the in the comic
books he's from a planet called half
world and that's where he was you know
modified and I guess made the way that
he is and I think they're gonna start to
explore that a little bit more but we'll
see and that'd be fun that's really
interesting so first of all I love here
you get a rogue a because I love her
hunting them so that's up there on your
side oh cool thank you turnabout yes
yeah uh okay so you get that one I love
the idea of Gamora
listening to them for like a split
second I'm like wait you're our friend
right and then just defeating all of the
remaining Guardians herself and like
putting them in a big stupid net ever
different is like carrying the man yeah
basically have a giant net yeah it's
like animal crossing right now
and then I think I was gonna ask you who
the villains gonna be but it sounds like
you're going for something on half world
yeah essentially I think this is gonna
be a bit more of the backstory type
situation I think maybe we'll come
across someone on half world but
obviously there's gonna be a lot of
different conflict here you know with
Kimora hunting them and rock it maybe
coming across a lot of you know turmoil
and confronting his creators later yeah
Baker yeah that's really interesting if
there's like a rocket version of kind of
the Weapon X story yeah all right
there's some of those theories that like
maybe Herbert Windham the High
Evolutionary could be tied in right cuz
didn't he have some appearances with
like Adam warlock and he like
experiments on animals to kill it he
could be a he could be like a maker
figure yeah it's just uh Sid from Toy
Story different animals together in
space on a throne it's I like it Matt
speaking of giant freaks on an island
honestly I love the idea of her as a
bounty hunter but I mean look here's the
situation right
she's plucked out of 2013 right Canon
she doesn't know the Guardians she just
knows she hates Danna she's still
technically in line with a nose I have a
feeling now that her you know her evil
kind of slave driving father is dead and
she secretly hated him forever because
the beginning of guardians 1 she was
kind of in line with him but she hated
him she didn't really know she didn't
have a way out but she wasn't she didn't
see the way she didn't know who Kevin
Bacon was she couldn't be a good guy so
I think that now now that she's kind of
she hasn't been tainted by the humanity
of the guardians and by Peter quill I
feel like she's just gonna become kind
of baby Thanos to a degree she's got the
sanctuary - oh we have a we have a
essentially like a deleted scene of her
walking away but we don't really know if
she walks away or not right if we don't
know if that's canon or not we do know
that she does exist
she is alive she is currently in hiding
because quill wasn't able to find her
I also were kind of were undercutting
the whole thor of it all like he is
going to be in some part in guardians
three so i know that i would love the
idea of there being like a love triangle
i love the idea of the her memory
essentially he's wiped a Peter quill so
she's kind of in between shows really
know who she's gonna like she might like
the worse you might like star-lord we're
don't really know but I love the idea of
trying to like rebuild your humanity and
trying to remind her that she's actually
not as evil as a warlord of a father she
can be something better but we kind of
have to build that up from start I love
the idea of actually giving Gamora like
the time that she needs interesting so
if if Thanos is Hitler obviously and
then the Hitler and all of the Nazi
armies were dusted and then cupola is
the very famous daughter of Hitler that
everyone knows Madeline Albright
there is there is still Nazi
sympathizers that would exist in the
country that now are looking for a
leader to fill the vacant spot right so
there it's the it's not famous it's army
necessarily but all the people that
looked up to Thanos and worshipped
Thanos right now need someone and she's
basically Mia Farrow sites is what they
call them neo famous everyone yeah Neos
Inez yeah III do think that she I love
the idea that she still wants to kind of
find herself and all of this and doesn't
want to be evil but I have a feeling
based on the fact that this is the
Gamora that was on you know the side of
the throne with Thanos and guardians one
it was like willing to go out there and
and and execute Ronan because he wasn't
doing with a nose wanted like she's not
she's not good yet so I still think that
she needs to do mind it that she's good
and I think that this is a great
opportunity for the rest of the
guardians now with Thor to kind of
remind her that she's not you know kind
of evil I think that would be really rad
story you definitely get a roadie for
Queen Gamora oh my goodness thank you oh
look what it became it became a Wheaties
box with my face on it terrible
decisions and decided to bleach my hair
no innocent dumb I was you were an
Olympian before all this I was
I was just I was and now I ruined it so
thank you for the we do you went for my
kids inspiration to a kids nightmare
figure a kid's paralysis demon in the
corner become go to sleep there it is
there like a specific kid Olympics
because I would love to go there and
just like booth yeah nobody to the
Mighty Ducks the Junior Olympic game
oh that's Joe yes I'm one of the the
Mighty Ducks it was me it was me
host Kenan Thompson and end of list yeah
and the other thing but the children are
the Nazis exactly to stop the child
warned
yeah they're John Iceland team yeah
Albright is Hitler's daughter he doesn't
know history it's okay Eric you say
you're gonna out rogue these two yes do
it they are giving my theory time to
gestate it is now ready to burst out of
my chest and frighten you all okay so
just like in a nutshell my theory is
that
gomorrah's survival from the invents of
the infinity war represents a cosmic
imbalance and the only way that she can
write that balance is by proving to the
Living Tribunal that she can murder all
twenty Celestials alright what oh crap
okay so think about it
Thanos was on this quest to balance the
universe right and he wanted to wipe out
half of all life and the way he did that
was by killing his daughter figure gum
or yeah her name's more yeah how did you
just have the most credibility to the
least credibility in two sentences we're
gonna cut it where that's how I know you
can getting the name Gamora means that
there's something wrong in your head
well I thought I had said nebula out
loud and I was like I say nebula no I
said more I'm good I'm good I'm good
okay so we killed Gamora look at this he
got the soul stone and then her death
ended up contributing to this cosmic
balancing well the Avengers kind of
cheated right they cheated with the time
heist to be able to write Thanos his
wrongs but and the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline in the comics when people
tried
do that The Living Tribunal as the
cosmic judge of all the universe says no
they anis didn't violate any natural
laws he was right to do this well
imagine a scenario where were in
guardians volume 3 right and then all
the Guardians who dusted in at the end
of infinity war start to get sick they
start to drop dead so you have like
Peter quill
Drex mantis they all start dropping dead
along with a random random half of
everyone Gamora realizes oh I was
supposed to die my survival screwed
everything up she appeals the Living
Tribunal and she's like this is [ __ ]
like what can I do to fix this is like
living tribunal goats look my hands are
tied
the reason why this mad Titan did what
he did is because his descendants were
these people by Celestials there are 20
of them across the cosmos and they
thought that they're right that their
legacy would be their favorite son the
eternal deviant Thanos who would wipe
out half of all life they thought in
their deluded view that that was the
right thing to do so they anis did this
but then these other earthly and
Avengers screwed it all up and they
cheated and they got away with it so the
only way Gamora that you can save half
of all life is take your sword the god
Slayer and go kill all 20 of these
Celestials and one by one she's gonna
take him down whoa isn't this gonna have
way worse ramifications we'll see I mean
what are the Celestials do we know one
of them is dead already that's the
severed head of a know where it was seem
to be okay and those dead
yeah egos gone so I think we're okay I
want to see like a Gamora like Scott
Pilgrim and Co first if I person and
take him down
that's the most active version of Gamora
if she's been given a second life right
like she her first life was spent her
blood was shed for this weird other goal
now she's given a second chance what's
the most exciting thing to see Kimura do
with the second life then to go
throughout the cosmos and rip off the
heads of these giant slashes when I was
in high school and I was going through a
dark phase I wrote a short story about a
man who wants to commune with God to
know why he lets all these bad things
happen and God doesn't have a good
answer so the
and kills God in order to I say well
we're better off without you you catch
me on this story like a year ago this is
not high school
oh it's gotten way more Erik only think
you need to answer you get first of all
yes you're gonna get one Rogi for this
little theory which the currency
exchange on my end is a sparkle buck hey
buck well that's worth a lot of thing
but you have to answer what do the
Guardians do in this movie other than
die it's their movie well the one suit I
died but some of them survived right so
Rockets survived he's still a bear
nebula her like adopted sister whatever
is also still alive so some of the
guardians are joining her on this
mystery but it's gonna be a thinned out
group of guardians right we don't need
to see the full guardians this is a
Gomorrah story Komori finding the glory
Rick and gomorrah everybody
what about grill routes not there but
we're gonna see a lot of great britain
for for no good and then maybe she's
able to bring them back right as we go
into the third act finale just like we
saw in avengers endgame everyone came
back we're gonna have everybody come our
dance assemble moment and in my were
summoned eights
groot and in catch them like that rocket
is gonna kill the one above all her like
he's gonna have yeah adorable all right
Eric um because you went so rogue you do
get a second rookie oh you mean a second
Sparkle back I almost want him to win
because I won about how many he has I
know I was just thinking about shows
like what different colors you have yeah
I don't know about you guys mine are
coming they're printing out of my USB
port on my knee so that's yeah I don't I
only have as many as Rogan all right I
love it let's hear him back in a tweet
okay so my tweet would be got more of
Gamora and then : the Bounty Hunter
how's that
you you sound like her trying to
communicate with someone
punctuation you know it's it's like if
you were counting syllables a little bit
but it was like more because that was my
way of all capting it for you guys I've
been doing it a bounty hunter mm-hmm
okay cool real easy to understand tweet
Matt we got mine is it's a word in
between clap emojis so think of it as
I'm saying it y'all sleepin on
kimura as baby Thanos literally the
exact same tweet the last time you were
on the show I don't know what you're
talking about this is this is how I
tweet this is every tweet I do is clap
emojis I make sure y'all understand me
I'm fine with this as long as somebody
sends in fanart
of baby Thanos that looks like baby Yoda
baby Groot just an adorable baby Thanos
we need a baby Cinematic Universe like
Muppet Babies exactly villains yeah I
love it all right Eric okay so my tweet
is just one tweet from gamora's account
and it's the only tweet she post just
follow anyone and it just says Guardians
assemble and then you just look over at
every Twitter account of the celestials
and then all their accounts have been
taken town oh this is this is like an AR
game that is it yes it's like somebody
needs to have been following all of them
and notice that they got taken - this is
like an AMC published 11 herbs and three
spices I love it I do appreciate that
Eric is trying to keep the Twitter part
interesting to himself even though his
tweets are making less and less sense
each week me that makes sense all right
all right let us know in the comments
who is the most close to what's gonna
happen or who is saying the story that
you wish we'd get on how we get Kimora
back really quick before we move on huge
thank you too
Bres VPN for sponsoring this show the
show needs sponsors so if you like this
show then you who hopefully like
expressvpn you guys know that expressvpn
we've talked about it before on the
channel it protects your privacy and
your security online but it actually
this is newer to some people but this is
why I've always used VPNs it helps you
unlock movies and shows that you can
only watch in other countries I swear by
VPNs honestly you can't watch Burkhardt
in the US on Netflix but you can in
Canada with the VPN really hard yep
oh to pay for CBS oh heck yeah you can
also watch Rick and Morty if you say
here in France also on Netflix just
globe trotting out the time when you're
locked inside just pretend you're in
different countries yeah either way all
you do you fire up its press bpn app you
change your location then you refresh
Netflix or Hulu or whatever you're using
regardless where you live and you know
what now that we're in this digital age
borders don't matter anymore let's live
in a post border world because that's
yeah Internet sees us it's just these
big tech companies that think borders
should matter
yeah Streeters Without Borders is our
new charity that we're starting speaking
of ways to steal some of these identity
expressvpn also hide your IP address so
you can technically do some browsing and
no one knows it's you if you're working
to powwow what you're looking at online
you can still choose from a hundred
different countries to say where you are
supposedly there are hundreds of VPNs
out there but a good reason to use
expressvpn one of the reasons that we
use it is that it's probably it seems
like it might be the fastest one there's
never any buffering or any lag you
stream HD fine without any problems and
if it's not clear you can use it on all
your devices your phones your media
console so as an old man would say it
your Smart TV or whatever so you can
watch on a personal device or on a big
screen wherever you are alright to visit
our link right now if you can it's
Express VPN dot-com slash rogue ro gue a
lot of people spell it Rouge and I'm so
sorry about the public school system
failing you you can get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free three
freaking months and you also support the
show which we appreciate so much you
also get to watch what you want to watch
without having to sign up for too many
extra star
says so protect yourself with expressvpn
expressvpn comm slash Rogue rogue ro gue
now it's time for our newest segment the
discord theory of the week so each week
we play a version of rogue theory on our
discord with our patrons only
we select at random three different
players and then they all pitch their
theory this one was about pitching how
the Fantastic Four will be introduced
into the MCU avenge nerd had a really
good one that was personally my favorite
that I voted for bruco had a really good
one Dorothea Metz hadn't had a really
good one too
with all the votes in the winner this
was the closest one we've had yet
actually is Dorothy let's give it up for
Dorothy she tied the origin of the
Fantastic Four to all the gamma
radiation that was released from all the
Infinity Gauntlet
yeah maps but here's her we've heard a
versions of that theory before but she
actually goes the route of introducing
them through the Eternals movie and then
uses the Eternals to become trainers for
the Fantastic Four to guide them into
becoming the heroes that they're
becoming very rapidly based on their
recent mutations what do you guys think
of that
I like it it gives like the Eternals
something practical to do because right
now when I think about the Eternals it's
like oh some ancient history maybe it'll
establish mutant kind of MCU that sounds
cool but other than that and I don't
really know how what active role they're
gonna take in the future but having them
connected to the Fantastic Four that
sets up like the next couple phases in
my mind Oh totally yeah I love that I've
honestly I've literally leaned in the
same way Eric has with the turtles going
into x-men but I feel like having them
going to Fantastic Four might have more
immediate results um I'm in I think
that's pretty rad yeah and I want to see
some more Fantastic Four's so speaking
of seeing more of the Fantastic Four our
buddy Louis brown on discord two shared
this fan art of me Erik marina and Tommy
as the Fantastic Four which my favorite
part of this is that Eric looks like the
flame on hurt says yeah and Street
Ventura's they like that yeah just
burning alive I love it they don't tell
you it hurts
we started in Tommy's face is not made
of rocks he's just blushing really
[ __ ] guard there yeah he's a sweet
soul which matches his character all
right if you guys ever make fan out of
us we have to share it because we it
drives our ego and our happiness yeah
yeah you just feel good that people take
time to spend on that no more time Don
that let's move on guys to our 2nd rogue
theory topic are you ready yeah yeah how
many so you guys know tweeter you guys
have been following this all the last
two days trending have been various
spider-man movie titles and it's because
people are trying to make their claim
for what the best interpretation the
definitive version of spider-man has
been if you could only pick certain
spider-man movies to exist which is the
one you would pick and everyone
apparently disagrees so I want each of
you to pick amongst the Tobey Maguire
spider-man movies the Emma Stone's
ex-boyfriend spider-man movies Andrew
Garfield and then potentially also the
Tom Holland ones and then also you can
even go animated with the recent
animated film I bet I don't spoil
because wanna be if I can take it I but
which of these is the definitive take on
spider-man the spider-man movie if we
could only have one go rogue okay I'll
start so I as someone who loves pretty
much all of these spider-man movies the
other ones pitched by you other two are
probably gonna be also close favorites
of mine the definitive one that I think
like I could show this to any person who
has never seen a spider-man movie before
without explanation just watch this
you'll be fine
spider-man far from home okay bear with
me on this this popular movie that made
a billion dollars okay I think the MCU
spider-man is the best live-action
depiction we've had of the character
he's the one who actually seems like a
teenager
he's like smart in the right ways he's
dumb in the right ways he's like a
fanboy of the other Avengers as
the comic spider-man should be and he's
like fooled in the right way in
spider-man far from home like they
basically tell the classic Mysterio
story he comes off as a hero at the
beginning but of course as a villain but
they still managed to make it surprising
and crazy and weird that like the way
he's corrupting his his perception of
reality the way he ties into the history
of Tony Stark and the way they like call
back specific things from past MC movies
and past Raimi verse movies you have
like William good tarifa coming back
from Ironman and then you have Jay jonah
Jameson coming back from the Raimi films
like there's just the right amount of
fanservice and like it's the most like
deadly threat that any of these Avengers
face some some kind of tech that can
warp your view of reality like I would
like to see any of it your take on Tony
Stark slash Mysterio's tech I love to
see Tom Hall and Peter Parker rattled as
much as he is in this movie I don't
think we see any spider-man up to that
point as like rattled as he gets you
actually think it's better than the
first one i oh absolutely I think I
think it's definitely it's at least 20
percent better than spider-man
homecoming 2010 percentage that's
awesome at 20%
I've everything's on a percentage scale
for me that's operating at 78% oh yeah
yeah I have been since day one so I feel
like mine's gonna be a little
controversial but I'm gonna save avert
first spider-man movie and all my time
in 75 okay I'm talking about spider-man
1 it's the best buyer movie because we
have Tobey Maguire who's a meme and then
we've got you get over there baby he's
the original meme yeah okay so see ya
we've got Tobey Maguire he's a meme
we've got JK Simmons as J Jonas James
s'en lots of J's in there and he's also
kind of a meme like he's amazing he's so
good in that role I get that spider-man
you know just it's just it's perfect
okay I want to see your guys's
impressions in a second of it if you
have one but then we
so Green Goblin and that's home default
it's just such a good cast it's me Mabel
it's nostalgic and it's got its funny
moments and its quippy moments and it's
scary moments and that is my favorite
spider-man that's the best one I mean
that you might walk so all other
spider-man movies could run so it has a
place that is true and and maybe all
modern superhero movies by the very kind
of reinvented the genre but especially
not having to go the dark version but
Angelica's your threatens the thrust of
your main argument that it's me mobile
well it's me bullets a nostalgic and
there's amazing cast
it's a nostalgic because it's old
everything is on the small don't work
yeah it's like the first one the old one
you know that's why it's nostalgic and
you know as matt said you know it kind
of set up the whole franchise the whole
series of the spider-man give me give me
a defense of specifically Tobey
Maguire's take on Peter Parker though
like that guy uh okay wait you want
defense for Tobey Maguire defense
counsel he's amazing he's crying he's
brain works and memes so I'm just
thinking of like crying me right now I
hear you work I think it works you know
yeah sometimes it just comes out that
way but you know I think the thing with
Tobey Maguire that is great about the
first spider-man movie too is we see the
rise of spider-man we see him being made
and there's something really cool at
least for me I really like to watch
those origins story
type movies so so yeah I really like the
first spider-man movie because I got to
see the come up I got to see the
transformation as well yeah the exact
okay I'll give you the wish-fulfillment
side that that movie had that none of
the others really had as much where I
think we can all imagine in our heads
the exact moment where he's season is
full-length mirror that he's suddenly
jacked oh yeah that that transformation
scene is definitely one of the most
inspirational to a nerd
for those of you who remember the the
MTV Movie Awards Jack Black parody exact
same thing good look the exact same that
was more where the time he takes off his
glasses and you can see merely that's
like right yeah that's everyone's dream
is just suddenly everyone's dream is to
be able to fortaleza keep playing yeah
no but it's true cuz Tobey Maguire the
actor being able to get that jacked
actually proved like I guess it's
possible yeah yeah Tom Holland was
jacked before the movie starts
yeah Toby you know before you come true
right uh your dreams are weird alright
and I'd met the all encompassing yeah I
mean here's my thing okay so uh I will
always have always have a special place
in my heart for the Tobey Maguire ones
right sam raimi his life Sam Raimi his
love like the fact that he may or may
not be doing dr. strange is he is it's
official right it's official right isn't
officially confirmed I haven't read
anything official but that's amazing
that's awesome
and then he literally is more of a
pioneer in the cinematic superhero world
that I think most of the other directors
in that era so the faculty was able to
do that stuff and he's coming back to it
like he has potential to be another gun
in the MCU which i think is amazing gu
nn okay and but but my if you're asking
about the best cinematic spider-man or
the best spider-man movie let's start
with a movie the best spider-man movie
has to be spider-verse it's got every
spider-man it's got every spider-man
it's got nods to every different origin
story it's got new words and stories and
I will say in the opening three and a
half minutes of Chris Pine kind of
giving his Peter Parker that was more
spider-man to me than any other actor
that has played spider-man
he was quippy he was funny he was
confident he was able to get it like he
showed hubris it was perfect and I and
the fact that he's dead in that movie I
also think is amazing because I feel
like every spider-man movie you either
die though whatever you die the hero you
live long enough to see a third movie
and any one of these reference but it
did a place here too but a place to ever
live including the Taco Bell dog if you
look look at spider-man 1 & 2
I'm in one awesome spider-man to amazing
in my top 10 it's apartment 3 trash the
antrum profil movies amazing one finds
of these movies is not in your top 10
spider-man movies top 10 movies of all
10 spider-man spider-man movies ahbar
yeah it's just spider-verse spider-verse
Spider know the same thing with amazing
amazing one great amazing two hot trash
the the friggin what was it the dubstep
fight scene at the end of the movie was
awful right now then you've got Tom
Holland Tom of the first movie great
second movie fine we haven't seen a
third movie yet it could be trash we
don't know we have no idea right if they
try to integrate it into the rest of the
world and now sunk in the Medellin zone
was exactly it might be awful but the
fact that we get a spider-man a perfect
spider-man from beginning to end and
he's done this is the end of the Chris
Pine spider-man I think he's the best
spider-man hands-down also making that
movie because of the possibilities and
the fact that it could technically roll
in all the different spider verses I
think that that that movie is the best
spider-man movie hands-down
here's what I'll give you about the
opening monologue version a Spider Man
it's the only one and it's only by
virtue of the fact that all the other
ones have started with high school
students and this is like kind of a
grown man but it is the only one that
rings as heroic ya know like you this
guy is funny but also you're grateful
that he's around saving lives everyone
else like it like if I had like a gun to
my head and I heard like a squeaky voice
teen making jokes trying to save me I'd
be like can anyone else help anybody
he's going through puberty mm-hmm yeah
but I mean it works look I love I love
the jumper wire movies I think that
there's too much Toby not enough Spider
Man in those movies but that is just
kind of a problem what literally he
takes thirty times in three movies like
I was like I don't need to see half of
New York knows who he is at this point
the the Andrew Garfield ones are just
those are just their Twilight spider-man
and I was not a fan and the Tom Allen
ones are fine but the Tom on let's have
a possibility that they could get ruined
so I think that the fact that
spider-verse kind of lives inside of
this one movie and is a perfect
spider-man film and it has yet to be
tainted by Hollywood yeah now you're
completely ignoring Miles Morales here
and you know it's his movie and his arc
so it's still if this is your argument
for the definitive spider-man movie you
can't unless you're saying it's the
first three minutes of that movie and
nothing else you gotta explain why the
Miles Morales story is actually part of
the definitive town of spider if you're
looking at it inside of like the scope
of every Spider Man movie this is the
first time that they're retelling the
same origin story over and over again
but it's completely different and we're
surprised every minute right you might
have known that Prowler was his uncle
you might have read the comics you know
I had an idea but I was still at the end
of the day I read all the comics I was
so shocked and surprised when that
became a thing like the fact that
they're able to do that like what comic
book fan is going to a spider-man movie
and dumbfounded but Uncle Ben dies you
don't mean like that not a thing that
happens the fact that they were able to
do that and they were able to bring that
level of storytelling just something
that we've seen a hundred times before
is amazing like that yes Maya Morales is
an amazing spider-man in that movie so
if you can only show someone one
spider-man movie to you by two verse one
hundred percent okay alright
you notice I didn't hand out any roadies
this round it's because I didn't want to
influence anybody's take on their movies
but the best argued case I gotta say is
Matt you so much it became a Funko pop
of me that's so weird I'm starting to
see a theme with all these rogue E's
that's so bizarre obsessed with yourself
so I still want to hear everybody just
pitch them back to us in a tweet ignore
the Rogi that I just gave out
this is you're fighting for the people
in the comment section to say who of you
is right here so in a tweet give it to
me why your movie is the definitive
spider-man movie ok my tweet is simple
spider-man does not become true
spider-man until he mistakes ac/dc for
Led Zeppelin hash tag so mine would
probably be just a compilation of memes
from spider-man and then basically say
that the first spider-man movie is the
best because we see the come-up of
spider-man we see his creation so I
guess in a tweet it would be the origin
story of spider-man
a series of memes and at least five
different ones a tobey maguire crying to
be fair hers is the thing that I
imagined very easily on Twitter
ya know it's very much I can see
trending immediately yeah
pick your favorite meme and then that
would he got so clap emojis in between
getting honestly I think I the tweet is
simple saying asking for your favorite
spider-man movie is getting only one
wish and why not wish for a million
wishes and that is spider-man into the
spider verse yeah
back to game guys alright there's not
that many Roku's out there right now but
the game completely changed based on how
this goes it's time for Road questions
okay number one Disney Plus used digital
fur technology to cover up a mermaids
bare ass in the movie splash how else
should we be using digital fur
technology to improve a Disney classic
easy it's the one thing we've all
thought when you watch both Incredibles
1 and Incredibles 2 what's the one thing
that we feel like it's missing we'll say
to the fullest the same time ready 1 2 3
beard Elastigirl curves more Jack Jack I
just want every every single member of
the Incredibles family getting a digital
beard added after the fact 100% all I
want that's all I want that's all we
need really ok that's great
bye hear me out ok what if we did a
live-action goofy movie and everyone's
in fur technology it would be terrifying
like you know where did that weird
winnie-the-pooh movie that came out
where they made him look too real yeah
exactly yeah yeah yeah I mean I could
see it happening so so live-action goofy
movie with the fur technology and we've
got I don't know like Jim Carrey as
goofy and I'm trying to I I don't maybe
like Tom Holland
I don't know going along with the
spider-man theme here Tom Holland as Max
or something you know I could see it
nice everybody
okay so maybe they fix everything wrong
with song of the south by turning the
singing slaves into singing
bears nope would not would not help that
no I don't think it would help that I'll
send it I'll texture the lyrics after
this all right question number 2 sam
raimi is confirmed to direct dr. strange
too which is so crazy because the rumor
we'd heard was that scott derrickson
wanted to make a horror movie and disney
didn't agree so then they brought in Sam
Raimi anyway uh his movies often include
Bruce Campbell in some way or another
this is our ash who is an epic character
who should Bruce Campbell be at least a
cameo in in dr. strange - I mean ghost
writer right ooh
Bruce Campbell you can play one Marvel
character and that character's name is
ghost writer ha I don't know I mean if
my bet is Mephisto
I would love a Bruce Campbell Mephisto
mare that'd be so dope uh so how about
Bruce Campbell just as himself gene saw
hands oh yeah yeah yeah as Bruce
Campbell does yeah personality wise but
with chain saws for him I'm gonna make
sense he did call me Bruce like I could
see him as Bruce Campbell as Bruce
Campbell like he's one of Raimi's best
friends like what uh you know he's
always playing some weird offhand
character
let him be a celebrity Bruce Campbell
all right finally third question you
ready I came out this week that the
original draft of rise of Skywalker had
Babu Frick dying he died give me your
best impression of Babu Frick dying it's
all dark it's tech news it's darkness
and cool
[Applause]
boo-boo oh wow that was really that was
really dark Eric okay
I'm trying to roll Babu sounds exactly
like oh hi Babu shriek eyes go oh that's
a little cuter really III mean I'm not
to go too charactery but I feel like
he's such a positive guy like everything
he did was literally like helping these
rebels and doing stuff I feel like even
like very much Matt you get the Rogi of
that round can I get oh my goodness
continuing the theme what it's the
neverending story oh my goodness I'll
finish this after thank you I appreciate
it thank you so much and is that you as
it's me as its me is it ray it's Matt
ray yeah yeah all right what are your
totals guys I am - sparkle bucks 100 so
marry the grown man who obviously would
have the most children's toys happens to
prove it Matt Rob you're our winner this
one we're goodness thank you guys thank
you for having me Raghu II I appreciate
it
that's not my name I know that and it's
a slur um Matt did you prepare a wish
for us as we go into our goodbyes I feel
like Angelica you need to tweet one
spider-man meme for the next five days
whoa wait every day you said there's so
many memes there's so many memes let's
see five of them would joga every day of
that many days they're like I'm saying
for the next month all right fine I
accept
you got an extra shout out of your
Twitter handle to make sure our fans
keep you honest I wish Angelica it is so
my twitter handles the same as my twitch
it's a tray ayy tra e and I will be
watching every day and I'll be reach
waiting and watching
alright everyone that make sure to
follow me sure to follow Angelica and
make sure she's posting those memes uh
all right guys uh thank you so much for
going rogue this was a delight thank you
Matt and Thank You Angelica
great job this week I don't forget to
subscribe to wrote their podcast feed
and make sure to follow Matt and Eric
also on social media and also this
channel is a podcast so follow it there
but also follow the Twitter at new rock
stars follow me at villa Molina on
Twitter and Instagram and go to the next
press ppm link it helps a lot yeah
thanks
[Music]